Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du gut ins neue Jahr gekommen?
Ja, du weißt ja, wie ich ins neue Jahr gekommen bin.
Stimmt, wir haben ja zusammengefasst.
Ja, war glaube ich ganz gut.
Stimmt, wir waren in der Oper zu Silvester.
Richtig.
Und die endete schon 21 Uhr, weil die alten Leute zur Party wollten.
Richtig, aber wir ja auch noch. Ja, insofern sind wir beide gut ins neue Jahr
gekommen, beschäftigen uns mit Literatur, beschäftigen uns aber auch mit Ergüssen von CEOs,
die jetzt auch Gastbeiträge in Zeitungen veröffentlichen.
Zum Beispiel Elon Musk schreibt in der Welt, warum die AfD die einzige Rettung
noch für Deutschland ist.
Also jetzt hast du gesagt, Elon Musk hat den geschrieben. Ich habe ihn nicht gelesen.
Ja, ich hörte aber, wie dieser Artikel zustande gekommen ist.
Man hat es sich ja jetzt nochmal genauer angesehen und es scheint wohl so zu
sein, dass 93 Prozent dieses Artikels AI generiert sind.
Ja, was ich finde, the medium is the message.
Wir müssen darüber eigentlich mehr reden, als geredet wurde.
Ja.
Denn nicht nur hat Elon Musk eigentlich keine Probleme in Öffentlichkeit zu
finden. Ihm gehört ja Twitter.
Sondern, dass er ausweicht auf andere Medien.
Und allein, dass er ausweicht, ist ja schon Thema gewesen.
Aber das Handwerkliche, die Manufaktur dieses Textes,
Wo es ja wirklich unterirdisch gewesen sei. Ich kenne natürlich nur den letzten
Satz, der nochmal auf Alice Weidel und so hinausläuft, irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Ja, dass Alice Weidel nicht Hitler ist, da sie eine lesbische Frau ist, so nett war.
Das kennen wir ja von Garth Saad.
Ja, da musste ich direkt dran denken. Garth Saad, das ist ja der Philosoph,
den Elon Musk so toll findet, aber Philosoph wirklich in Anführungszeichen,
der dann sagte, ich habe gerne Hunde, Hitler hatte gerne Hunde,
bin ich jetzt etwa Hitler.
Ja, ja. Daraufhin, als wir den Clip im Podcast spielten, haben uns ja Leute
darauf hingewiesen, dass das ja ironisch war.
Ja, ja, ja.
Dass das ja etwas aufzeigen sollte.
Nee, das zeigt eigentlich nichts auf. Das zeigt auf, wie blöd diese Leute sind.
Ja, genau, es hat sich viel aufgezeigt.
Ja, es ist sehr interessant. Und die Frage ist ja, warum veröffentlicht er in
der Welt? Also die Welt ist ja kein Medium, wo man vorkommen muss.
Das ist eine Zeitung, die lesen so wenige Leute, dass sie noch nicht mal mehr
als Bordbeilage im ICE liegt. So war das ja früher in der ersten Klasse.
Ist auch passé, weil das Ding immer liegen geblieben ist.
Es wird ein paar Paywall-Leute geben, aber eigentlich ist das ja unter ferner
Liefen. Also hätte Elon Musk das in diesem Podcast hier gesagt,
hätten das vermutlich mehr gehört.
Aber dadurch, dass es natürlich dann publiziert wurde, er publiziert in der
Welt einen Artikel pro AfD, hat es natürlich entsprechende Wellen geschlagen
und die Frage ist, wie ist dieser Artikel da reingekommen? Diese Frage kann
man nicht klar beantworten.
Es gibt aber einen sehr interessanten Artikel im aktuellen Spiegel von Vicky Bagel und Anton Reiner.
Die schreiben über die, sagen wir, Verbindungen zwischen Matthias Döpfner und
Elon Musk. Und dort ist zum Beispiel zu lesen, im vorvergangenen Jahr feierte Döpfner seinen 60.
Geburtstag in einer Villa im italienischen Luca.
Eine Berichterstattung darüber ließ er juristisch unterbinden mit der Begründung,
sie sei nicht von öffentlichem Interesse, es sei eine rein private Party gewesen.
Die Gäste hätten die Kameras ihrer Handys abkleben müssen, heißt es.
Unter den Feiernden war, so berichten es mehrere Quellen übereinstimmt, Elon Musk berichtet.
Und er war dabei nach Spiegelinformationen nicht allein.
Als Begleitung habe er die rechtsradikale niederländische Influencerin Eva Fladingbröck eingeflogen.
Fladingerbröck heißt sie. Bekannt als Reporterin des rechtspopulistischen Portals
News und politische Aktivistin.
Regelmäßig verbreitet sie rechtsextreme Verschwörungsmythen,
etwa über den vermeintlichen großen Austausch. Auch sie habe mit Döpfner gefeiert, heißt es.
So, wir wissen auch, dass es eine Nähe gibt zwischen Peter Thiel und Matthias Döpfner.
Wir wissen, wie sehr Peter Thiel gerade die Trump-Administration zusammenstellt.
Gibt es da überhaupt irgendjemand, der nicht im Office von Peter Thiel arbeitet, fragt man sich.
Es sind wenige jedenfalls. Und wir haben auch hier noch dokumentiert,
im Frühjahr 2022 schrieb Döpfner eine Nachricht an Elon Musk.
Zu der Zeit stritt das Unternehmen Twitter, wie die Plattform X ursprünglich
hieß, mit Musk über dessen geplante Übernahme. Die Nachrichten wurden während
eines Gerichtsverfahrens in den USA offengelegt.
Döpfner schrieb, warum kaufst du nicht Twitter? Wir managen es für dich und
errichten eine wahre Plattform für freie Meinungsäußerung. Also dieser Artikel
ist ganz interessant, der zeigt die Seilschöpf.
Ich verweise nochmal auf unseren Salon zu Peter Thiel, da sieht man ein bisschen,
wes Geisteskind eher ist.
Und meine These ist ja, wir erleben jetzt in Österreich, dass die Rechtsextremen
an die Macht kommen und es ist nicht mehr ein großer Protest da und es ist auch so,
dass die, sagen wir mal, Industriellen in Österreich.
FPÖ gut finden und die ÖVP gut finden und eigentlich jetzt sagen, das ist ein Match.
Die ÖVP wollte ja zum Beispiel die Mehrwertsteuer anheben,
dagegen hat sich die SPÖ gestellt, dann hatten natürlich auch die Liberalen
da noch ihren Anteil, dass das nicht zustande kam, aber man kann sehen,
also es sollte eigentlich wieder Druck mehr auf die ausgeübt werden,
die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, die nicht so viel haben.
Und jetzt sieht man, wie sich also aus dem Kapitalismus durchaus wieder faschistische
Strömungen herausentwickeln und die passen auch dann wunderbar zusammen,
den Industriellen ist es ganz recht.
Ich glaube, ganz so weit sind wir noch nicht in Deutschland.
Was wir aber erleben können und ich glaube auch nicht, dass Friedrich Merz einer
wäre, der eine solche Koalition machen würde, also eine schwarz-blaue Koalition, um das klar zu sagen.
Ich glaube aber, dass es in der CDU Leute gibt, bei denen man sich fragen kann,
ob es noch so große Unterschiede gibt.
Nicht zwischen der Höcke AfD. Aber wenn wir jetzt gerade sehen,
wie Weidel sich fällt, wenn wir auch sehen, dass KRA durchaus transatlantischer
sich jetzt gerade äußert,
und uns ansehen, nicht was einzelne Redakteure jetzt bei der Welt gegen diese
Veröffentlichung sagen.
Also die sind ja im Prinzip kleine Angestellte. Auch wenn sie große Namen haben,
sind sie kleine Angestellte.
Aber was da sich so an der Spitze tut und Peter Thiel und all das.
Dann glaube ich schon erleben wir jetzt gerade, Dass man an der einen Hand noch
Margot Friedländer führt und mit der anderen schon nach Alice Weidel greift.
Ja, das ist genau das Bild. Liebe Frau Friedländer, liebe Margot.
Und da wird nochmal tief ausgeatmet und im Grunde ist sie auch so ein bisschen
mediale Geißel, weil sie ist 103 Jahre oder so.
Sie kann sich ja nicht wehren, sie kann ja nicht wie Marcel Reich-Ranitzky auf
die Bühne stürmen und sagen, genug mit dem Theater und so. Ja.
Also in der Hinsicht, das sind wirklich interessante Zeiten,
die allerletzten Holocaust-überlebenden Leute noch auf der Bühne mit das Ende ein.
Unwissendlich, die sind dem ausgeliefert.
Ja genau, also mit 103 Jahren ist man dem Leben ausgeliefert,
also sie ist sozusagen sowieso entschuldigt.
Du hast mir ja eben schon verraten, dass du das Buch, das wir heute lesen, nicht so gut fandest.
Ich finde es entsetzlich.
Entsetzlich, du wolltest es abbrechen.
Ich hatte die Idee, dir zu schreiben, wir lassen es, wir nehmen was anderes.
Was ein Dovum ist.
Und du sitzt hier mir gegenüber und sagst, ich habe so viele Notizen,
war aber auch wirklich gut.
Also ich bin wirklich überrascht, weil ich hatte, also wir können ja kurz in
die Manufaktur hier uns auch mal offenbaren.
Typischerweise reden wir überhaupt gar nicht über das gemeinsame Buch,
bis wir dann im Podcast darüber reden.
Also dass ich gerade überhaupt noch mal vorher so gesagt hätte,
ich fand das Buch gut. und du nicht, ist schon interessant.
Ja.
Insbesondere mit dem Verweis auf, wo ist der Widerstand?
Sollten wir nicht, wenn der amerikanische Präsident sagt, wir fallen in den
Irak ein, eine Million Leute auf der Straße haben und zwar bis Februar.
Und jetzt wird irgendwie Grönland. Und wo ist der Widerstand?
Ich habe heute Morgen eine Story
aus der Bundeskanzlerin, also ich habe es re-shared, das ist ganz witzig.
Typischerweise stehen wir ja unseren Regierungen kritisch gegenüber.
Wir sind ja mündige Bürger, aufgeweckt und nicht dem Pöbel dazugehörig,
dem sich der Bundeskanzler allerdings verschreiben muss. Der braucht ja eine Mehrheit.
Und ich erwische mich, dass ich den Bundeskanzler teile.
Und zwar unkommentiert in voller Länge, wie er es gesagt hat,
nachdem er Kanada, also nachdem Kanada Thema war.
Und das finde ich schon ganz interessant, weil wir das jetzt auf einer Ebene
verhandeln, die wir alle nicht persönlich kennen, aber aus Erinnerungen immer so mitschleppen.
Die gute Gesellschaft, es findet eine Klausur statt, Leute treffen sich in Seon
oder wie es heißt oder wo auch immer.
Oder sind in Erwartung von solchen Treffen. Und dann hängt das Schicksal der
Welt davon ab, wie so eine Interaktion verläuft.
Also das transaktionale Bündnis, dass man dann spontan eingeht mit Trump,
weil er halt zugegen ist. In der einen Stunde klärt sich einfach, wie es so läuft.
Wenn sich da Leute zerstreiten, zerstreiten die sich. Und dann wird das auch
die nächsten vier Jahre nicht gekittet. Irgendwer wird abgewählt und so.
Und dann mal gucken, wie es mit dem Nächsten läuft. Also irgendwie so.
Wir haben eine Gesellschaft, die sich darüber verständigt, wo ich auch sagen
muss, ich habe ja schon immer so gedacht, wozu denn Demonstrationen auf der Straße?
Also ich habe mich ja häufiger nicht kritisch, sondern eher so nachfragen, wozu?
Also wenn jetzt 20.000 Leute in Frankfurt eine Demo machen und Frankfurt ist
keine besonders große Stadt, nicht mal eine Millionenstadt, dann bekomme ich das hier nicht mit.
Und wenn ich es mitbekomme, erfahre ich vielleicht noch zu welchem Thema,
aber von Argumentation und so sind wir ja ganz weit weg.
So, jetzt haben wir also kein öffentlich sichtbaren Widerstand gegen Trump.
Leute sind mit Feuern in Los Angeles und Neuwahlen in Deutschland beschäftigt.
In Österreich auch kaum Demonstrationen gegen Kickel.
Genau, Österreich passiert. Als Haider damals kam, gab es ja gleich EU-Sanktionen und sowas.
Ja, da war richtig was los in Wien.
Genau. Und das wird nach alter Seegewohnheit noch als, aha, jetzt haben wir
so Defizite, wir sind zu nachlässig, die Zivilgesellschaft müsste mal und so weiter.
Aber das Angebot, das sie hat, ist ja nur in alte Muster zurückzufallen.
Also jetzt ein Demo-Zug durch Frankfurt, also das ist ja absurd.
Von daher werbe ich so ein bisschen für eine neue Sensibilität,
die Interaktionen ernst zu nehmen.
Gefühle und Gemütszustände, wir lernen hier gleich einen neuen Grundbegriff
kennen, den du wahrscheinlich einfach überlesen hast, aber ich werde dir das
nochmal und den Hörern auch vorstellen.
Und Ruhmann hat ins Büro Bücher mitgebracht, zum Beispiel dieses Umgangsformen
heute, aber dieses heute ist 1970, entsprechend ist es produziert.
Es ist ein krasser Schmöcker.
Und vielleicht kann ich noch kurz sagen, wir hatten die Woche auch ein Corporate
Therapy aufgenommen mit Mary und Humann über das Buch Süß von Ann-Christin Klusty
und im Kontrast dazu Rutger Breschmanns,
worüber wir häufiger, was ist mit dieser Arroganz und Überheblichkeit der Mächtigen,
wir haben dies geschafft durch diese Ochsentour durchzukommen,
um am Ende das große Medienspiel zu machen.
Und da kamen wir drauf zu sprechen, das ist auch ein Gespräch von Lars Weißbrot
mit Ijoma Mangold in deren Podcast, die sogenannte Gegenwart kam,
wo die beiden sich über Streit unterhalten haben, in dem Lars Weißbrot aber
darauf hinwies mit Nina Power, die sind ja in so einem Dreier,
aber immer nur Dialogwechsel,
mit Nina Power konnte ich mich ordentlich streiten, mit dir,
Ijoma, bleibe ich lieber da, was die Regeln erlauben.
Und das ist, finde ich, der Kern dessen, was uns künftig beschäftigen wird, ganz doll.
Überall halten wir uns noch an Regeln, die sozusagen eine dritte Partei,
eine Institution, eine Geschichte, eine Tradition, wie auch immer,
also eine dritte Entität hat
so Regeln aufgeworfen und damit wir nicht ins völlig orientierungslose.
Unbefleckte Land sozusagen kommen, orientieren wir uns an der Regel.
Oder, also das wäre sozusagen das Verhältnis Ischoma-Mango, Glas-Weidbrot.
Oder klären wir es alles künftig wie Lars Weißbrot mit Nina Power streiten wir
uns, auch jenseits der Regel, weil wir wissen, dass die persönliche Beziehung es aushält.
Wir brauchen keine dritte Kraft, wir brauchen kein überbordendes,
irgendwas befehlgebendes, ich will es mal so befehlgebend sagen.
Und das ist super interessant, weil dieses Buch von 1970, das ein echter Schmöker
ist, hier geht es ums Prominieren während Tanzveranstaltungen. Veranstaltung.
Ja, ganz wichtig.
Oder Theater. Was ist der große Unterschied? Die Pause im Theater,
die Pause beim Tanz. Beim Tanz,
zeigt man den anderen Anwesenden, was man von einer Person hält. Man tanzt mit ihr.
Man weiß aber, diese Person ist nicht alleine. Sie hat ein soziales Netz mit
sich, Familie. Wir begrüßen also in der Pause die Familie.
Ausgiebig. Die Pause ist nur dafür da, das soziale Netz der Person,
mit der wir zum Tanz erschienen sind, zu grüßen, zu begrüßen und zu huldigen.
Im Theater, in der Pause grüßen wir beiläufig Anwesende, die wir kennen.
Denn die Pause dient dem Gespräch über das Theater.
Wie geht man mit Alkohol um?
In dem Fall ist der Tipp, wir stellen Flaschen oder Gläser, die wie Weingläser,
also Weingläser, aber wir füllen da auch Saft ein und so.
Es muss bunt aussehen, niemand soll sehen, dass wir kein Alkohol trinken,
aber man muss jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit Alkohol trinken.
Schlagen wir unsere Ehefrauen? Nein, das machen wir natürlich nicht.
Die christliche Lehre und so weiter gilt hier nicht mehr.
Wir machen das ein bisschen auf Augenhöhe. Wir wissen alle, wie das abläuft.
Human hatte auch noch parallel dazu ein zweites Buch, Sekretärinnenwitze, aus derselben Zeit.
Das sind 50 Seiten anrüchiges Zeug.
Da bleibt von diesem Anstandsding. Aber das Witzige ist, in diesem Buch wird
deutlich, wir klären es vor Ort miteinander.
Wir haben keinen Twitter in der Hosentasche. Niemand postet und Shitpostet uns
irgendwie. Keiner macht einen Shitstorm, weil irgendwas beobachtet wurde.
Alles wird in Interaktion geklärt. Es gibt gar keine überbordenden Regeln.
Es gibt nur so Gewohnheiten, Traditionen, an die man sich hält.
So, und jetzt will ich eine Beobachtung schildern. Also dieses Buch,
das ist ein echter Schmöker, da kann man so richtig seitenweise reinspringen.
Es war wieder Kongress. Und ich war das erste Mal 2012 beim Chaos Communication Kongress.
Genau, also der Chaos Computer Club macht am Jahresende eine große Veranstaltung.
Es treffen sich so 10.000 plus Leute und gründen so für vier Tage ihre eigene kleine Welt.
Abgeschottet, Grenzziehung, diejenigen, die ein Ticket haben und die anderen.
So, und dann sind halt die, die ein Ticket haben dort.
Und 2012 war das Jahr, in dem auch der Kongress gerade von Berlin nach Hamburg gewechselt ist.
Also aus einer, wir haben hier Assemblies, kleine Gruppen rotten sich zusammen
und dann zeigt jeder dem anderen, was man so tut.
Und das Bühnenprogramm ist sozusagen nebensächlich.
Hatte man in Hamburg plötzlich einen Saal mit 2000, 3000 Sitzplätzen.
Also riesig, riesiger Rang.
Da könnte man sozusagen so einen kommunistischen Parteitag machen.
Und dann kam eine Idee auf, dass man nämlich auf der Bühne steht und sagt,
damit das hier alles ein bisschen schneller geht, defragmentiert doch mal den Saal.
Also Leute, die neben sich einen leeren Sitzplatz haben, rücken einfach auf,
damit die Leute, die vom Rand kommen, sich sofort reinsetzen können und nicht
erst aufstehen, durchgehen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich sitze aber gerne am Rand.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein echtes Problem. So, 2012 fanden alle das eine mega
Idee, schon allein, weil der Lindworm das als defragmentieren gelabelt hat.
Toll.
Und alle so wussten, ah, defragmentieren, technischer Begriff,
ich bin ja ein Techie, also mache ich das jetzt. Ich weiß sofort,
was gemeint ist, ich fülle die Lücke auf.
So, aber es war auch, glaube ich, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es vorher war in Berlin,
als es alles so kuschelig und klein, die Männer unter sich und so weiter.
Es war der Beginn einer deklarativen Moral. Jemand stand auf der Bühne und hat
gesagt, wir defragmentieren jetzt.
Wir klären es nicht unter uns. Es ist mir egal, wer da zwei Sitze weiter sitzt.
Du rutschst jetzt einfach eins auf.
In dieser Zeit, in der dann auch die Bühne immer größer wurde,
in Leipzig war ja nochmal mehr Sitzplätze, glaube ich, und alles riesig,
hat plötzlich diese deklarative Moral überhand genommen.
Also man kommt ins Kongresszentrum ein in Hamburg und da hängt sofort eine Fahne
All creatures are welcome.
Und zwar nicht als, so ist es hier, sondern das ist ein Befehl.
Verhalte dich hier bitte ordentlich. Frage nach Konsent. Und wir wissen,
wir haben da keinen öffentlichen Sex, sondern bei allem wird bitte Konsent abgefragt.
Also es ist einfach so ein deklaratives Momentum drin, bei dem man sich fragt,
aber ich sehe dich doch mir gegenüber, können wir es nicht einfach unter uns klären?
Müssen wir jetzt alles dem großen Herrgott und so weiter ausliefern?
Und dieses Jahr hat es für mich so ein bisschen umgeschlagen.
Also es war mir zu viel. Und es gab eine Situation, die da ganz interessant war.
Ich saß mit Robert in Saal 1 und wir saßen am Rand.
Und dann kam von vorne der Befehl zu defragmentieren. Da die Pausen zwischen
den Talks ein bisschen länger waren, 25 Minuten, war es 25 Minuten lang aufstehen,
reinrücken, macht Platz für die Leute, die jetzt reinkommen.
Es war sozusagen Faktor C nerviger, als mir am Bahnhof zu erklären,
dass ich bitte hier vor Taschendieben und so weiter meine Sachen auch,
ja, es war wirklich nervig.
Und dann hat der Typ hinter uns einfach gerufen, und was ist mit denen,
die Angststörungen haben? Die möchten am Rand sitzen.
Und der Typ auf der Bühne wusste nicht mehr weiter. Er war sozusagen schachmatt.
Ja, er war in seiner Wognes einfach schachmatt gesetzt, weil,
ach klar, Angststörungen.
Und in dem Moment habe ich auch gedacht, wir sitzen alle gern am Rand und wir
brauchen dafür auch keine Entschuldigung.
Also ich muss jetzt nicht vorlügen, ich hätte hier mega Angst vor den Leuten,
die hier sind, vor der friedlichsten Crowd der Welt, muss ich plötzlich lügen,
ich hätte Angst, um mal am Rand sitzen zu dürfen.
Nein, ich komme zuerst in den Saal, Umgangsform heute, ich setze mich an den Rand.
Wer später kommt, trägt leider das Los, in der Mitte zu sitzen.
Und es widersprach komplett dieser deklarative Moral, die mir von der Bühne
vier Tage lang reingehämmert wurde.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, man kann aus Verlegenheit von mir aus 20 Minuten lang
auf der Bühne Witze erzählen und so weiter.
Also Leute wie Pupo oder so, die machen das wunderbar. Die stehen dann da und,
wissen so ein bisschen, wie der Wind weht und erzählen dann Geschichten von
der letzten Nacht und wie auch immer.
Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die aus völliger Verlegenheit, die selber nicht
wissen, warum stehe ich hier auf einer Bühne?
Warum habe ich mich bereit erklärt, hier zu engeln? Warum bin ich ein Herrheit?
Und dann müssen die irgendwie, ich habe ein Mikrofon in der Hand,
ich mache mal defragmentieren.
So. Und dann gehen die auf den Sack, weil sie glauben, deklarative Moral,
darauf haben wir uns geeinigt, das ist das Ding.
Und ich würde sagen, 2025 ist nicht mehr.
Ich will keine deklarative Moral mehr.
Wir haben das als Vorwurf schon häufiger thematisiert, weil nämlich den Woken
immer unterstellt wird, die hätten eine deklarative Moral und ich würde jetzt sagen, das stimmt.
Nur die ganzen Neurechten, die haben eben auch eine deklarative Moral.
Nur eine andere, ja.
Ich will nicht, dass mir irgendwer erzählt, wie ich mit irgendwem umzugehen
habe. Oh, da kommt ein Ausländer, der wird jetzt gehasst. Nee,
das ist deklarative Moral.
Die hat für uns so ein umgedrehtes Vorzeichen, aber ich sage das trotzdem,
das fällt nur um Moral. Ich will keine deklarative Moral mehr. Ich will jetzt...
Für 2025, das ist mein Aufruf, bitte interaktives Bulldozern.
Ich weiß, ich als Mann, groß gewachsen und so weiter, ich Bulldozer sowieso.
Aber, nachdem ich jetzt so ein bisschen sensibilisiert wurde,
ich wünsche mir das auch von anderen.
Wenn im Hotel ein Frühstücksbuffet ist und man sieht eine Einflugschneise,
um vorzudrängeln, um sich ein Ei zu holen, stellt man sich bitte nicht in diese
Schlange und wartet, bis Oma Erna fertig ist mit dem Rührei.
Dass ein Meter weiter vorne steht.
Die Leute, die dann am Buffet überholen und mal kurz über eine Schulter drüber
greifen, um sich was zu nehmen, machen es richtig.
Die sind nicht zu verurteilen, weil sie gegen irgendeine sittlichen Gebote und so weiter und so fort.
Sondern sie haben gesehen, ich schaffe das ohne zu berühren.
Wir klären das hier unter uns.
Wenn jemand was dagegen hat, einfach ansprechen und sagen, dieses Verhalten
finde ich gerade blöd. Okay, dann muss man sich halt anstellen.
Aber solange das keiner anspricht, muss man nicht vorauseilend,
und was mich besonders nervt, eine Situation, also eine Standardsituation.
Ja, nachts im Dunkeln als Fußgänger vor der roten Ampel und stehen bleiben.
Genau, also in New York ist es jetzt erlaubt, es gibt keine Fußgängerampel mehr.
Es gibt Verkehrsleitsysteme für Autos. Wenn rot ist, irgendwas,
man darf als Fußgänger rübergehen, immer.
Wenn man kann.
Wenn man kann. Man muss es halt
für sich klären und mit den Autofahrern so ein bisschen und so weiter.
So, diese Situation, wenn ich auf ein Fahrrad komme und eine Oma steht auf dem
drei Meter breiten Weg, hat einen Hund dabei und zieht den Hund dann so ganz
ängstlich zu sich, guckt mich an und deutet mir noch so, ich habe ihn hier wegfrei gemacht.
Dann ist das für mich fast wie eine Anklage, weil sie, ich, also ich, mein Selbstbild,
vermittelt aus ihrer Perspektive ist dann, ich sehe so gefährlich aus und so
unfähig mein Fahrrad zu steuern, dass ich sie totfahren würde,
aber sie hat sich jetzt aus dem Weg geworfen, sozusagen Lang für mich,
ja. Nur ich wollte ja nur da langfahren.
Gut, können wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen auseinanderhalten,
weil jetzt kommt ja hier alles zusammen, jetzt kann ich das kaum noch entwirren.
Also das eine ist ja eine deklarative Moral.
Da weiß ich, was du meinst. Ich wundere mich bisweilen, wenn ich zum Beispiel
im Rahmen einer Gewerkschaft einen Vortrag halte,
dass zum Beispiel bei der Ankündigung oder irgendwo auch nochmal hingeschrieben
wird, dass man gegen Homophobie zum Beispiel ist. Wo ich denke, ja, was denn sonst?
Muss man es nochmal hinschreiben? Will man es nochmal extra sagen den Leuten?
Was passiert, wenn man ihnen das nicht sagt?
Würde mich auch mal interessieren bei Verdi oder so. Also ein bisschen eigenartig,
ja, nur so als ein Beispiel mal.
Und da kann ich das sehr nachvollziehen. Jetzt ist es ja so,
was du da schilderst mit diesen Reihen, Massen sind mit Unterträge.
Ich weiß das auch, wenn man zum Beispiel eine Veranstaltung macht mit Pause.
Dann ist das sehr, sehr schwierig, Leute nach 20 Minuten wieder in einen Saal zu buxieren.
Und ohne Gewalt. Und deshalb kann ich natürlich auch verstehen,
dass man da gewisse deklarative Momente und Appelle hat, damit das funktioniert.
Das andere, was du ja da gerade ansprichst und das ist ja dem auch geschuld,
dass man es geschmeidig halten will eigentlich, ist ja, dass du dich gerne so
ein bisschen schneller durchbewegen würdest.
Und das ist natürlich so, dass wenn man in einer größeren Stadt lebt,
man sieht, dass es also verschiedene Tempi gibt, in denen sich Menschen durch die Welt bewegen.
Und das hat auch nicht immer was mit, weil jetzt werden manche sagen,
ja die Vulnerablen und so, auf die achtet natürlich Stefan wieder nicht.
Dann würde ich sagen, nee, nee, nee.
Also wenn man zum Beispiel, was ich jetzt habe, mehrmals in Frankfurt unterwegs
über die Zahl geht oder so, da bummeln eben Leute, das ist ja auch ihr Recht,
dass sie da bummeln dürfen,
nur ist das vielleicht nicht meine Sache und ich würde auch sagen,
ich finde es ganz gut, wenn man Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung mit unter hat,
aber ich fände es auch schön, wenn man mal die Zahl, die auf dem Schild steht, auch erreicht.
Ja, dass man also nicht, wenn 50 steht, versucht es mit 20 zu machen.
Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo ich auch mir etwas mehr Flexibilität und Dynamik wünsche.
Und da beim Hotel ist es tatsächlich inzwischen so, dass ich wieder dazu übergehe,
das Frühstück abzublasen, weil ich das nicht mehr aushalte.
Also genau, das ist nämlich der Ausweg, dass man einfach in die Vermeidung geht.
Beim Frühstück wäre das noch zu verschmerzen, aber es gibt sehr viele Sachen,
das Wort ergreifen, das Wort behalten, wie auch immer. dieses höfliche zurückschrecken,
klein beigeben und so weiter und so fort.
Also es ist keine Sache des Regelwerks.
Ich mag es weder, wenn Leute erstmal auf die Regeln verweisen,
nachdem sie ein Wort bekommen haben oder so Sprüche machen wie ach sehr schön,
dass eine Frau hier auch mal was sagen darf oder wie auch immer.
Also dieses schnippische Deklarieren von Moral finde ich genauso nervig,
wie auf der Bühne diese ewig langen Präampeln, die irgendwie abgefeuert werden.
Plakate, die da irgendwie hängen, die wirklich Humor befreit bis zuletzt.
Die Hauptsache, alle fühlen sich auf der sicheren Seite.
Ich möchte jetzt, dass wieder Spielräume erarbeitet werden.
Ja, und auch Selbstverständlichkeiten nicht nochmal benannt werden.
Genau, Selbstverständlichkeiten sind Selbstverständlichkeiten.
Also ich muss im Jahr 2024 bei einer Gewerkschaftsveranstaltung oder auch bei
irgendeiner Uni-Veranstaltung nicht darauf hinweisen, dass man gegen Homophobie
ist. Das ist selbstverständlich.
Wenn jemand sich da deviant verhält, gehört der geahndet.
Dann muss man das sanktionieren.
Aber ich muss nicht jede Selbstverständlichkeit, muss ich nochmal schreiben,
ich schreibe dir jetzt auch nicht morgens ein SMS, wenn ich aus dem Auto heute
bei dir aussteige, erwarte ich, dass du mich begrüßt.
Davon gehe ich aus, dass du das tun wirst.
Und dieses, dann muss das angesprochen werden, das ist eben diese zweite Seite dieser Medaille.
Wenn man von sich selbst das Gefühl hat, ach, ich bin ja irgendwie ängstlich,
Ich finde es ganz gut, dass es so Regeln gibt und wenn die dann mal gebrochen werden,
Dann hoffe ich einfach, dass die Leute einfach wissen, was die Regeln sind,
ohne dass ich es jetzt nochmal ansprechen muss. Nee, dann muss man es ansprechen.
Also dieses berühmte, wie verhalte ich mich jetzt zu Weihnachten am Familientisch,
wenn Onkel Egon irgendwas sagt.
Das sind genau die Momente, wo man dann reingehen muss.
Also wo man in Interaktion und im persönlichen Gespräch, wo man sich nicht verlassen
kann, auf dritte Größen das klären muss.
Ich finde es ganz erstaunlich und die Bandbreite der Effekte und Wirkungen und
warum das ein politisches Thema ist, sind riesig. Das werden wir dieses Jahr auch sehen.
Aber ich finde es ganz erstaunlich, dass wir einen medialen Diskurs darüber haben,
dass in Österreich jetzt die FPÖ regiert und irgendwie mit Trump und dann Musk
im Schlepptau, dass jetzt in Europa, in jedem Land plötzlich diese Hofierung der Neurechten gibt.
Und wir jetzt ja auch, sagen wir mal so ein 25-Jähriger, der ist mit 15 irgendwie
bewusst geworden, dass man ja und so weiter am medialen Geschehen teilnehmen
kann, der kennt also nur Trump und Musk, also wir wissen gar nicht, was das bedeutet und so.
Und wir haben so einen medialen Diskurs, der einfach ausblendet,
dass diese Leute nicht einfach mit Ich habe die größten Raketen und die Elektroautobranche
ist irgendwie meine oder sowas,
sondern die haben relevante, große Teile der Bevölkerung hinter sich.
Also die ARD sendet immer, als ob nicht ein Drittel ihrer Zuschauer AfD-Sympathisanten
wären, sondern für alle so ganz selbstverständlich, oh, jetzt kommt das Monster
des Rechtsradikalismus und so.
Dabei sind es die eigenen Zuschauer, es ist die eigene Belegschaft,
es ist die eigene Nachbarschaft, es ist die eigene Familie.
Und es wird völlig ausgeblendet, weil man sich auf so ein Regelwerk verlässt
und, ach ja, war schon immer so, Artikel 1 ist natürlich, ja,
also ich habe noch hier diese Schlesinger vom RWB, bevor sie da gefeuert wurde, die da noch beim...
Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland bei diesem Reporterforum treffen da und so auf
der Bühne sitzt, ja, ja, also bei Artikel 1 bin ich total parteiisch.
Und dann sieht man das aber in dem Programm gar nicht. Also da kommt dann einfach
Merz zum Gespräch und darf dann kurz sagen, ja, natürlich wollen wir gar keine
Ausländer hier haben und so.
Und da wird dann einfach drauf vertraut, dass dann, ja, der Zuschauer weiß jetzt
schon, dass das nicht okay ist, oder? Das muss ich hier nicht klären.
Ich kann jetzt einfach sozusagen die Talking Points abdingeln und so.
Ich glaube, was wir jetzt eigentlich erleben ist, dass wir eine große Normalisierung haben,
die ja auch da zu sehen ist, wenn zum Beispiel Linnemann oder Merz sagen, dass die,
die eine Doppelstaatsbürgerschaft haben, die Deutsche abgeben müssen,
wenn sie zweimal straffällig werden, das heißt also Staatsbürgerschaft ist dann
doch wieder an was geknüpft, an das Blut und nicht mehr hält man sich dann offenbar ans Grundgesetz.
Also man sagt dann auch, dass man natürlich großen Abstand zur AfD hält,
aber ich würde gerne mal wissen,
wenn man jetzt so Namen nennt wie Jens Spahn oder jetzt bei Springer Matthias
Döpfner oder Ulf Poschert,
wer kann mir denn mal die fundamentalen Unterschiede zu Alice Weidel aufzeigen?
Es gibt ja noch zwei Punkte, die sind ja tatsächlich strittig.
Das ist einmal die transatlantische Verbindung.
Jetzt hat Alice Weidel auch mal sowas gesagt, ja wir sind ja quasi die Sklaven der USA.
Das wirft sie mal so dahin. In Wahrheit aber sehen wir ja, wie die AfD immer
transatlantischer wird.
Das Vorbild ist da, Georgia Meloni. Sogar Maximilian Krah scheint sich von China
ja loszulösen und richtet sich auch immer mehr auf Elon Musk und Donald Trump aus.
Wir haben zugleich eine Entwicklung, bei der wir sehen einen Präsidenten in
den USA, der sagt, Grönland wäre gut zu haben.
Außerdem auch noch Kanada und gleichzeitig sagt der grüne Kanzlerkandidat in
Deutschland, wir brauchen mehr transatlantische Partnerschaft und das 3,5 Prozent Ziel.
Ja was denn, um Grönland zu erobern, um Kanada zu okkupieren, was machen wir damit?
Also das würde man gerne mal wissen. Und was man jetzt eben sehen kann ist,
also diese transatlantische Sache ist auf jeden Fall bei der AfD jetzt ein Ding
und die bewegen sich in die Richtung.
Und der zweite Punkt, der noch kritisch ist und der ist ja auch schon krar auf
die Füße gefallen und deswegen wollte ja Weidel auch schon mal Höcke ausrangieren,
auch wenn sie den jetzt wieder näher an sich annimmt, ist natürlich die deutsche
Vergangenheit, Stichwort Holocaust. Wie geht man damit um?
Wenn da jetzt noch ein Umgang gefunden wird, der natürlich sensibler sein muss
als das, was Kickl jetzt da macht, weil der muss sich nicht distanzieren,
die sehen sich als Opfer, die österreichischen Rechtsextremen,
die konnten ja gar nichts dafür damals in den 30ern,
aber hier in Deutschland muss das ein bisschen differenzierter aussehen.
Und naja, eine Antwort wird ja bereits gegeben.
Es gibt ja geradezu mit der AfD einen Netanyahu-Fanklub und damit stellt man
unter Beweis, dass man aus der Geschichte gelernt hat.
Das ist ja auch quasi dann die Doktrin von Springer und das muss reichen.
Und sonst will man über Antisemitismus und so in Deutschland nur dann reden,
wenn er von Muslimen kommt.
So, und das ist quasi das Angebot, das gemacht wird. Und da wird es noch einige
Reibereien und so weiter geben.
Aber dann steht eigentlich auch einer schwarz-blauen Koalition in Zukunft,
nicht bei jetzt der Wahl, die uns ansteht, aber in Zukunft steht dem dann nichts mehr im Wege.
Und man wird sehen, dass auch dann,
Gerade die Springerpresse, aber auch andere private Medien werden da fröhlich
mitmachen und sagen, ja so ist es jetzt leider oder naja wirtschaftspolitisch
ist es aber auch vernünftig, was immer dann meint, also mehr Sozialkürzungen,
mehr Lohndruck und so weiter.
Ja, all das sind Probleme, die müssen jetzt, also da muss man diskursfähig sein.
Wenn man Journalist ist und man sieht solche Probleme, muss man Oma Erna erklären
können, wo liegt das Problem.
Man muss da eine funktionale Analyse. Ein Verweis auf das Grundgesetz,
ein Verweis auf Geschichte, auf irgendwas ist alles nichts wert.
Also das hilft niemandem weiter. Keine Deklaration, keine Moral, sondern Achtung.
Also dieses interaktive Prinzip. Ich habe ja Blumanns Moral der Gesellschaft
da entsprechend empfohlen.
Das sind diese Bücher der Stunde. Und so finde ich eben auch Eva Illus.
Ja, wir sprechen über dieses Buch, Explosive Moderne von Eva Illus.
Ich sage es gleich, das Buch ist Mist, aber Stefan findet es großartig.
Ich finde es genial. Man kann nicht besser in dieses Jahr starten als mit diesem Buch.
Ich möchte empfehlen, dass die, also so eine Soziologie braucht wirklich gar
keinen Menschen, das ist auch keine Soziologie, das ist schlechte Literaturwissenschaft.
Wir werden darüber diskutieren, ich glaube aber es ist symptomatisch für unsere
Zeit, dass so ein Buch jetzt da erscheint und ja auch viel Lob bekommen hat.
Also du bist ja jetzt nicht der Einzige, der das lobt, um das schon mal deutlich
zu sagen. Ich bin da eher, glaube ich, in der Minderheitenposition.
Also muss hart kämpfen, aber das werden wir im Salon tun.
Außerdem habe ich was Schönes. Guck mal hier, wie opulent.
Das ist die große neue Lagerfeldbiografie, die den Titel trägt Paradise Now.
Über die wird zu reden sein. Dann habe ich einen Roman von einer türkischen
Autorin, beziehungsweise es ist eine deutsche Autorin, sie hat den auf Deutsch
geschrieben, kommt ursprünglich aus der Türkei, Tesa Özlü.
Dieser Roman ist aber 40 Jahre alt, ist nie auf Deutsch erschienen,
ist aber auf Deutsch geschrieben und erscheint jetzt zum ersten Mal. Hochinteressant.
Dann gibt es einen langen Essay zum Thema Netflix, zum Casual Viewing,
nämlich Netflix produziert Filme für Leute, die gar nicht gucken,
sondern die Filme hören.
Wie hören?
Naja, man kann die Filme gucken, aber man muss, um die Hals zu verstehen,
muss man sie nicht gucken.
Es ist wirklich hochinteressant, wie sich das alles dort verschoben hat.
Naja, das ist ja heute Journal und Tagesthemen. Das sind ja Nachrichtensendungen,
die die Bilder nicht brauchen.
Richtig, aber bei Filmen hatte man sich ja mal darauf geeinigt,
dass das Bild eigentlich das Wichtigste ist und wie es mit einem visuellen Medium zu tun hat.
Es reicht doch, wenn alle drei Jahre ein Nolan-Film kommt.
Nein.
Nein. Und ich habe dieses sehr lange Interview gelesen, das Adam Toos einem
chinesischen Magazin gegeben hat,
in dem er sich verortet als engagierter Intellektueller, sich gegen gewisse
marxistische Theoretiker stellt, aber auch ein bisschen was gegen MMT sagt.
Es ist ein hoch, hoch interessantes Interview.
Man lernt sehr viel und vielleicht kann man sich da auch selbst nochmal sehr gut dran verorten.
Und es gibt auch noch Musik, diesmal Brahms. Okay.
Wir lesen, nachdem ich ja früher schon darauf hinwies, auf das Buch von Livia
Gerster über die Neuen im Bundestag.
Michael Schlieben hat in der Zeit so eine Bilanz gezogen, die leitende Generation Kühnert.
Das ist eigentlich aus diesen 49 geworden.
Außerdem, wie werden wir mit 2025 fertig? Aus reinem Amüsement.
Es gab eine lange Liste in der Zeit.
Mehrere Autoren haben Vorschläge gemacht für das Jahr. Mehr oder weniger absurde.
Außerdem der Think Tank von Ian Bremmer, der bekannt dafür ist,
immer mal so ein bisschen populäre geopolitische Aussagen und so zu machen,
hat jetzt die großen globalen Risiken aufgeschlüsselt.
Zehn Stück, die gehen wir mal durch.
Also sozusagen Überblicksarbeit.
Und Hoss und Hopf haben ein Buch.
Man muss das sagen, für die Leute, die das nicht kennen, also Horst und Hopf
ist so ein rechtsradikaler Podcast.
Also er ist nicht rechtsradikal, aber.
Er ist so ein Podcast, der sagt, Deutschland ist nicht mehr Deutschland.
Er hasst Bitcoin, geht nach Dubai und beobachtet von dort aus Deutschland,
wie es den Bach herunter geht.
Genau, was wir ja kennen aus vielerlei Richtungen.
Damit kann man gut Geld machen.
Damit kann man gut Publikum aufbauen und dieses Buch ist, also ich kann kurz
schildern, ich hatte es nicht in der Hand und uns interessieren auch nicht die Inhalte.
Dieses Buch hat 365 Kapitel, nämlich
für jeden Tag soll man eine kurze Motivationsspritze und so weiter.
Also man liest jeden Tag noch so eine halbe Seite, toll.
In deren Podcast selber thematisieren sie, dass der eine zu dem anderen sagt,
ja und um mich überraschen zu lassen, habe ich ja auch deine Sachen gar nicht
gelesen, bevor wir es in Druck gegeben haben. Das ist ja eine besonders interessante Herangehensweise.
Und wir lesen nichts aus dem Buch, sondern wir lesen die Spitzenrezensionen aus Deutschland.
Dieses Buch hat auf Amazon über 800 Rezensionen. Wir fragen uns natürlich alle 200.000 Verkäufe.
Wer hat das denn so gekauft? Also wir lesen die Rezension der verifizierten Käufer.
Das hat sich 200.000 mal verkauft?
Sagen die selber.
Na gut, man klasse ja bei Mediakontroll.
Genau, also es wird schon irgendwie so hinhauen. Nur die Frage ist halt,
wie kommt man zu 200.000 Verkäufen?
Und was sagen die Käufer? Also wir werden uns ein paar Gedanken über den Buchmarkt
machen, denn wir sind ja selber Teilnehmer des Buchmarkts.
Dazu kleiner Hinweis, auf deine Empfehlung hin, gibt es auch für die Kinderwüste eine Signieraktion.
Also die Frage, Stefan, wo soll ich dein Buch kaufen? wo hilfst dir am meisten,
ist endlich entschieden, es gibt eine Seite autorenwelt.de, bei der die Autoren
sogar beteiligt werden im Umsatz, das wusste ich gar nicht.
7% Ja, also wir kriegen von der Marge dieses Buchhändlers auch nochmal Geld.
Und ich kann ja kurz sagen, für das Autorsein an sich, kriegt man 10%,
da der Verlag mir gegenüber sehr gönnerhaft war, was ich gut finde, 11%.
Dieser Buchhändler legt nochmal 7% drauf. Also es ist sozusagen wie bei Amazon,
dieses Affiliate-Programm oder so.
Dadurch, dass die halt keine Schaufenster
und Lager, Toiletten für die Öffentlichkeit oder wie auch immer.
Aber ganz wichtig ist ja, was Autorenwelt anbietet, nämlich du signierst es
und du signierst es nicht nur, sondern du widmest es auch.
Man kann mir auch Widmungswünsche, also es bleibt dann nicht nur bei der Unterschrift.
Sondern ich nehme dann die ganze Palette und schlage mir einmal vor den Kopf
und sage, oh Gott, in jedes Buch jetzt individuell, aber keine Ahnung, wird schon klappen.
Also damit er auch mal ans Arbeiten kommt, bestellt das Buch.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie du das machen wirst. Also ich habe knapp 1000 Bücher
damals signieren müssen mit Ann-Christin zusammen und das hat viele Stunden gebraucht.
Aber wir haben nicht noch Widmungen reingeschrieben, weil ich dachte,
meine Handschrift ist so hässlich. Ich bin froh, wenn ich meinen Namen drin habe.
Die Widmungen sind Vorschläge. Also ich schreibe jetzt keine Geburtstagsgrüße
voller Länge ab, sondern kurz.
Okay, wir sind gespannt. Ja, und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr die 29er teilt,
weiterverbreitet, in WhatsApp-Gruppen verschickt.
Wenn ihr gute Kommentare da lasst auf den Plattformen, auf denen ihr das hört.
Und wir wären regelrecht begeistert, wenn ihr auch den Salon abonniert.
Das ist ja die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen und es ist
nicht nur eine Unterstützung,
sondern man bekommt auch was dafür, nämlich wir haben hier einige hunderte,
ich über tausend Seiten gelesen und wir werden jetzt gleich ausführlich über
Eva Illus und über die Soziologie streiten.
Ich weiß nicht, dass Wolfgang und ich auch mal nicht einer Meinung sind.
Heute geschieht es, das kann ich ja ganz.
Ganz bestensprechen.
Jedenfalls ist das ganz einfach, den Salon zu abonnieren. Man kann das über
Apple tun, wenn man den Podcast.de über Apple hört.
Dort braucht man dann nur das Anklicken und sofort ist man drin für, ich glaube, 3,90 Euro.
3 Euro im Monat.
Ja, bei Apple ist es etwas teurer wegen der Gebühr.
Bei Apple gibt es aber einen Probemonat.
Ah, okay.
Man kann bei Apple sich warm hören und dann bei Steady für drei Euro buchen.
Und bei Steady, richtig, kann man für drei Euro buchen. Das heißt,
man geht auf die Seite neue20er.de.
Da ist ein goldener Button, auf den klickt man, da kommt man sofort zu Steady.
Es ist kinderleicht, man kann den Podcast dann einfach immer so weiterhören,
wie man das jetzt auch tut.
Man kann es also auf seinem Podcatcher sich anhören wer bei Patreon ist kann
auch dort den Podcast finden findet auch dort alles aus den letzten Jahren ich
glaube die ersten anderthalb Jahre sind nicht dabei,
aber auch Patreon wer da schon ist, kann dort ein Abo abschließen,
ab 3 Euro im Monat ist man dabei und da würden wir uns freuen,
wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt und wir sollten vielleicht jetzt noch sagen,
die Live-Termine.
Es ist ja so, dass wir im Salon schon gesagt haben, dass wir wieder vier Live-Salons
machen und jetzt hatten die quasi das Vorzugsrecht und nun sind aber noch ein paar Karten zu haben.
Die erste Veranstaltung, der erste Salon ist ja schon ausverkauft im März,
aber im Juni könnte noch was frei sein.
Also von allen Tickets sind ungefähr, oder waren vor Weihnachten noch so ein
Drittel. Also viel ist es nicht, aber die Termine sind.
Ja, März ist weg, dann aber den 6.
Genau. 20. Juni. Ja.
20. 6. Freitag.
Freitag, dann Freitag, der 19. September und Freitag, der 19. Dezember.
Und die Mail ist neue20er at diekäs.de Käs mit A-E, aber das ist in den Shownotes
verlinkt, wie man so schön sagen.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich zu einem heißen Streit im Salon.
Ich werde Wolfgang auf die neuen Grundbegriffe weichklopfen.
Es ist nicht nur Gefühle und Gemütszustand, es kommt ein neuer hinzu.
Ich habe viele Gefühle beim Lesen dieses Buches gehabt. Aber keine positiven.
Bis gleich.